[Music]
these days it's natural to feel a bit
lost
everyone seems to be looking for a sense
for where they stand in the world
a reference point on which to ground
ourselves a mental map
when we think of our mental maps of the
actual world however
that is our intuitive sense for the
shape and relative position of places on
the planet
it may surprise you to learn that
they're a bit off
many people's mental maps of earth in
fact share the same
fairly significant errors relative
positions
sizes and even the existence of minor
locations
may be totally off base the good news is
it's not your fault
one reason for a skewed mental picture
of the world is our brains taking
shortcuts
our minds try to simplify the layout of
highly detailed things
such as the locations of cities and
countries around the world
but these shortcuts may not always be
accurate take for example south america
many may think it's located more or less
directly south of north
america with chile corresponding roughly
to california
if you flew straight south from los
angeles however you wouldn't hit land
again until antarctica
in reality all of continental south
america is located
east of florida in this way north and
south america could also accurately be
named
west and east america respectively these
mental misconceptions
aren't limited to the americas do you
think of africa as being largely in the
southern hemisphere
perhaps at similar latitudes of south
america
in fact the vast majority of africa is
north of the equator
i bet you never realize that disney
world in orlando florida
is closer to the equator than the great
pyramid of giza in
egypt europe is also much further north
than many people realize
a line drawn west out of london england
would never touch the 48 contiguous
states
paris is actually further north in
montreal
barcelona is around the same latitude as
chicago
our mental image of europe being further
south than it actually is
may have to do with its weather europe
has what's called a mediterranean
climate
the result of warm air crossing the
atlantic via the gulf stream
this means that many european cities
have climates that those of us in the
americas
associate with lower latitudes when we
think about the weather in
say venice we don't expect it to be
located further north than toronto
but it is a skewed sense of the world
isn't just
our brain's fault for taking shortcuts
every map you've ever seen
has been in some way distorted from
reality
for instance many of us grew up with
maps in school
that show greenland to be about the same
size as south america
in reality however south america is more
than eight
times larger than greenland similarly
most maps make it impossible to see that
brazil
is larger than the contiguous united
states and only slightly smaller than
canada
or that alaska is actually smaller than
libya
now how is it possible that maps can be
so misleading
the answer lies in the impossibility of
representing
a three-dimensional object the earth in
only two dimensions
a map while a globe can accurately
represent
relative positions sizes and distances
on the earth's surface without issue
compromises must be made when trying to
flatten an orb
into a map cartographers people who make
maps
have developed various methods of
depicting the round earth on a flat
surface
called projections each of these
projections
represents the earth accurately in some
way while distorting the planet in
others
for instance one of the most common
projections is the mercator projection
introduced in 1569 by gerardus mercator
mercator maps are found in classrooms
around the world and it's even the
projection used by google maps
mercator's goal in developing his
projection was to aid in navigation
any angle on the globe is the same angle
on a mercator map
which assured navigators that they were
heading towards their intended
destination
in the days before gps as a result
however the relative
sizes and shapes of continents on
mercator maps are distorted
especially for land nearer to the poles
as you move further away from the
equator the mercator projection
shows land taking up more area than it
actually does on earth
this is why antarctica looks so large
while in reality
being the third smallest continent as a
result mercator projections tend to
portray northern countries
such as those in europe as being larger
than they actually
are remember how far north london
actually is
some scholars maintain that these
countries magnification has contributed
to an imperialist mindset
essentially allowing small european
countries to inflate their position on
the world
while the mercator is one of the most
commonly found around and of the world
it is far from the only projection
available each like the mercator has its
own benefits and drawbacks
none is considered more correct than any
other they're all trying to solve the
same impossible problem
converting something from three
dimensions to two
the only representation of earth that
doesn't make any compromises
a globe apart from mental shortcuts and
distorted projections
there's another reason why your mental
map may be false
you've been intentionally lied to before
satellites were taking high resolution
photos of all the earth's surfaces 24
hours a day
making a map was a painstaking job if
you spent a ton of time
and resources making a map you needed
ways to ensure
people wouldn't copy your work and sell
it themselves as their own map
one way to do this was by putting
intentional errors in
maps called trap streets for instance
if you were mapping your hometown and
included a made up street
nothing serious maybe just a fictional
cul-de-sac in the corner of town
and that same fake cul-de-sac appeared
in a competitor's map
you could be confident they had stolen
your map
according to the grandson of the former
president and ceo
thomas brothers maps would put fake
streets of people's kids names
pets names in little cul-de-sacs and
that was one way we would be able to
keep the copyright
one of the most common descriptions of
map making is that it is both an
art and a science historians hypothesize
that human consciousness has always had
an impulse to try to cognitively map and
relate to our physical surroundings
and while human brains may instinctively
have an impulse to map
the practice is by no means an innate
skill leading to many distortions
in how we mentally believe the world is
laid out
it's important to keep in mind how just
like the projections of globes onto maps
the way we view our surroundings is only
one of many valid interpretations
sometimes
when you feel lost in the world changing
perspectives may be just what you need
to find your way
[Music]
you